this home for the elderly is located in
Kawasaki a city of over a million in the
greater Tokyo area the residents often
attend events like this concert of
Japanese folk songs
Saeko Adachi can sometimes be found in
the audience together with her mother
she runs chinko for koushik I the so
called social welfare corporation to
which the home belongs almost every day
her mother must sua katayama can be
found in the kitchen of one of the
nursing homes she loves to cook and
often prepares meals for new residents
or guests in Japan we have a saying
everyone eats from the same bowl sharing
meals brings us closer together that's
why I like to prepare the food so that
they should took them skin it the
Kawasaki home has many residents in need
of care in Japan care for the elderly is
becoming increasingly inadequate in the
past it was normal for children to take
care of their parents but now many can't
manage to do that because they have to
work and their living space is limited
30 years ago there was no government
supported care of the elderly
so my soui Katayama founded her own
homes that was a first in Japan and
criticized as an impossible task Japan
Chikara lots of people told me not to do
it
sono itami toka they said it couldn't
possibly work but that actually gave me
the strength to do it it's my challenge
Japan's demographics are changing
rapidly by 2030 more than a third of the
population is forecast to be over 65
years old rich people can afford
luxurious homes for their old age but
for the majority of people dependent on
normal pensions other solutions are
needed Masuya katayama is now 76 years
old today
her corporation runs more than 30 homes
she says maximizing profit is not the
goal we Japanese are good at many
different kinds of business dealings but
we're not social entrepreneurs people
wouldn't even think of trying to solve
social problems it
doesn't have priority I wanted to be a
businesswoman and also act in a socially
committed way the founders personal
touch is evident throughout her homes
it's of great importance to Masuya
Katayama
that residents should feel well cared
for and respected financing their homes
continues to be difficult though the
government pays a certain sum per place
and the residents contribute their
pensions the mother and daughter team
have to hunt for donors to cover special
costs and events it's also difficult for
them to find suitable personnel here
they're showing a group of interns from
Australia around the home they'd like to
hire more foreign workers Japanese tend
to be quite shy we don't express our
feeling well many Latin American
employees they naturally hug and
residence or they are very good at
showing their emotions especially with
their happy emotions no residence gets
really happy we didn't really like it
one reason for the staffing problems is
the caregivers are generally poorly paid
in some places in Japan robots are
already being used to carry out simple
tasks in elderly care I've got nothing
against robots they can be very helpful
but I don't want to be thanking a robot
during my last moments on this earth she
wants the residents to feel truly at
home in her homes